[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un vacación informativos 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia y aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
los ojos del mundo están sobre malí
donde el ex presidente ibrahim bubacar
keita fue liberado nueve días después
del golpe de estado que tuvo lugar en el
país las naciones de asia occidental
tienen que el poder le sea entregado a
los civiles
el continente africano superó el millón
doscientos mil casos de kobe 19 la
organización mundial de la salud asegura
que se hacen pocas pruebas al día pero
que el índice de mortalidad es inferior
a la media mundial hablamos con un
médico colombiano que trabaja en luanda
la capital de angola
tenemos para ustedes música de la
artista ecuatoguineano factory quien
éste no recientemente su nueva canción
titulada 12 desde malabo factor y le
envió un saludo a la audiencia de áfrica
7 días
[Música]
iniciamos entonces con la información
porque el expresidente mal ibrahim
buscar keita fue liberado nueve días
después de que militares doble tuviera y
lo obligarán a renunciar el bloque
regional de equis de países de áfrica
occidental insisten en devolverle el
poder a los civiles de la nación
detrás de estos muros se encuentra la
residencia del ex presidente de mali
ibrahim bubacar keita y es allí adonde
se dice que regresó tras su liberación
keita estaba detenido desde el 18 de
agosto cuando un grupo de militares lo
capturó y lo obligó a renunciar después
de varias semanas de protestas
ciudadanas en su contra según un
integrante de la familia del exlíder hay
guardias afuera de su casa y deben
aprobar la entrada de todos los
visitantes la junta de mali
autodenominada comité nacional para la
salvación del pueblo o cn sp ha
pospuesto permanecer en el poder durante
tres años hasta las próximas elecciones
mientras tanto la coalición de oposición
dijo que estaba dispuesta a trabajar con
los gobernantes militares el 9 está
activo
los dos actores principales en la
transición para el cambio esperado por
el pueblo de malí para el
establecimiento de un nuevo mal y deben
ser reconocidos
la mls de nuevo mal y los dos actores
claves son el m5 rcp y el cnsp
el anuncio de la liberación de keita se
produjo en vísperas de una cumbre
virtual de mandatarios de los países
vecinos de malí el bloque de 15 naciones
de áfrica occidental ya impuso sanciones
contra malí por el golpe de estado
hablamos ahora de kobe 19 porque el
continente africano superó los 1,2
millones de contagios la oms informó que
la tasa de letalidad del continente es
bastante inferior a la media mundial
esos son los 5 países más afectados por
la pandemia
sudáfrica continúa siendo el epicentro
de la enfermedad con más de 613 mil
positivos y 13.300 ocho decesos en
segundo lugar éste egipto que rodea los
98 mil contagios y suma más de 5 mil 200
muertos seguido de marruecos que rebasan
los 54 mil 500 casos pero cuya tasa de
sesos es inferior a la de nigeria que
cuenta mil siete muertos y más de 52 mil
contagios y en quinto lugar se encuentra
gana con casi 44 mil contagios y unos
200 fallecidos
pues en plan veinticuatro hablamos con
el médico colombiano jose francisco
fernández quien trabaja en luanda la
capital de angola desde hace dos años y
se encuentra ahora radicado en ciudad
del cabo en sudáfrica él nos contó de
primera mano cómo se vivió la crisis del
coi 19 en estos países
angola cerró sus fronteras desde la
tercera semana de marzo aún sin tener el
primer caso positivo de kobe 19 y empezó
con unas ciertas medidas descritas en su
plan nacional de contingencia
'vamos reglamento del sanitario
internacional siguiendo las medidas
obviamente estipuladas por la ms y eso
dijo que al principio había muy pocos
casos de coronavirus en el país
actualmente no se ha llegado al pico
cada vez más estamos viendo en las
clínicas hay a personas con síntomas
sospechosos de coronavirus
lastimosamente se hacen muy pocas
pruebas en el país alrededor de 2000
pruebas con millón de habitantes
mientras que por ejemplo comparándolo
con sudáfrica donde hace 61 mil pruebas
pues se queda muy corto para lo que
quisiéramos nosotros como médicos y
profesionales de salud
esto porque porque hay solamente dos
laboratorios que están realmente
haciendo la prueba de la reacción de la
cadena de polimerasa pcr
lo cual hace que los números continúen a
estar muy bajos y posiblemente mucho más
bajos de lo que estamos viendo nosotros
en la realidad de nuestra práctica
clínica mientras que en sudáfrica donde
vivo es el país más afectado del
continente y el quinto del mundo con más
de 600 mil casos y 13 mil muertes se
hacen como les digo aproximadamente unas
60.000 pruebas por millón de habitantes
y en este momento ya estamos en un nivel
2 de alertas del pasado 18 de agosto ya
pasamos por el pico en sudáfrica el pico
se pasó en la web a mediados de julio
al principio en el momento del pico se
llegaba alrededor de 11.000 casos
confirmados por día mientras que en esos
momentos en a finales de agosto estamos
alrededor de 3000 casos confirmados por
día y nunca se llegó a ocupar
completamente las camas de uci ni el
sistema de salud
pero mientras el continente lucha contra
el coi 19 también hay buenas noticias
porque ms celebró también la
erradicación oficial del virus de la
poliomielitis en el continente africano
una enfermedad que ha paralizado el
cuerpo de al menos 75.000 niños y niñas
en la cuna de la humanidad
mmmm y sola es una deportista nigeriana
de 28 años que a los 11 meses de nacida
contrajo poliomielitis una enfermedad
viral que produce debilidad muscular y
parálisis en cuestión de horas esto no
le impidió desarrollarse físicamente y
practicar actividades para volver más
fuerte su cuerpo
empecé a usar ropa grande porque pensé
que podía cubrir mi forma de caminar
pero obviamente no podía
llevar ropa muy grande también trata de
hacer un poco más masculina y de ocultar
todas mis emociones para que lo que
dijeran no me afectara
desde hace cuatro años el continente
africano no registra un solo caso de
polio la organización mundial de la
salud celebró la noticia y declaró
oficialmente erradicada la enfermedad
del continente
es uno de los mayores honores de mi vida
unirme a ustedes en la celebración de la
erradicación del poliovirus salvaje en
los 47 estados miembros de la región
africana de la umh la solución más
eficaz es la vacunación temprana ya que
los menores de 5 años son los más
vulnerables cambiamos de información y
vamos ahora a honduras donde viven los
garífunas una comunidad presente que
conserva su idioma africano y la mayoría
de sus costumbres ahora un misterioso
secuestro de varios de sus líderes
genera tensiones entre este pueblo
ancestral y el estado hondureño informa
nuestra corresponsal en kenia torres
desde el 18 de julio la vida no es la
misma para karen martínez desconsolada
espera el retorno de su hermano uno de
los cuatros garífunas secuestrados por
uniformados en la comunidad de triunfo
de la cruz al norte de honduras con
nunca pensamos que eran gente mala pues
entonces dijimos si autoridad los van a
llevar a una estación y vamos a que va a
ser el procedimiento que se tiene que
hacer como autoridad porque por eso más
mucha gente se confiaron porque entraron
bien informados bien armado igual nos
agarraron dormidos los cuatro
secuestrados luchaban por defender su
tierra del gobierno y empresarios que
quieren desarrollar un proyecto
turístico en la zona si nos encontramos
justamente aquí en la casa de milton
tienes donde los muchacho que fue
secuestrado como pueden ver pues una
persona que vivía de una forma bastante
humilde trabajadora
se dedicó a toda la vida a la pesca y al
mismo tiempo pues al pequeño segmento
del turismo pese a que un tribunal
internacional otorgó el derecho de esta
tierra a la etnia que se estableció en
honduras hace 223 años el estado no ha
respetado ese derecho la policía afirma
que sigue la búsqueda de los autores de
este secuestro
después de un equipo fuerte pero tenemos
avances sustanciales con él
de hecho
en la primera semana tuvo un
profesión sin embargo el temor y la
desconfianza prevalece en la comunidad
de casi 10.000 habitantes ya que los
secuestradores vestían ropa parecida a
la que usa la policía
no ha traído ni un gran miedo dentro de
la comunidad
no podemos ver un carro que no sea de la
comunidad como nosotros pensamos como
que vienen con nosotros vivos se los
llevaron vivos los queremos es la
consigna de la comunidad un lema que
mantiene la esperanza pero no impide el
temor y finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días con música desde
guinea ecuatorial el único país de
áfrica cuyo idioma oficial es el español
desde malabo hablamos con factory el
artista urbano estrenando su nuevo
sencillo titulado 12
estamos bailando de moda
y su organismo emocionados
activamos pues más que ese tema lo
grabamos este legal
con la ayuda negra de nuestros autores
aquí en áfrica
aquí es pondréis
y yo mismo soy un corruptor
y la canción tenía como objetivo hacer
algo grande ya sabéis que el verano
y ese es el tiempo en que la gente se
toma
es en ocasiones si quiere pasar la vida
[Música]
yo actualmente vivo emitieran y material
nosotros somos el único país que habla
hablar español en todo el continente
africano de hecho nos dedicamos bastante
todo lo que es
el continente americano sea
latinoamericana
más
y es por eso uno de los mejores de los
ritmos que accedemos a playas de barra
que todos lados
hoy es a título personal me gustaría que
que en américa latina se escuchará
música que es factor y que resistirá mi
movimiento
y de paso
y mandarle un saludo
áfrica siete días lo unimos informativo
con español se ha dedicado al continente
africano
[Música]
bueno
pues con esta buena música finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días pero
los invitamos a continuar con más de
nuestra página web plan 24 punto com nos
vemos más adelante con más información
quédense con nosotros
[Música]
y